the biggest jobs are normally the ones
you've got away with right so
I will say the most I've ever taken out
of a bank for example out of a Midland
Bank funny enough was 48 000 pound in
cash that's the most to get out of a
bank but what you've got to bear in mind
is this
if people are robbing building societies
and they're just doing the tools on the
bank you're talking about five six
between five and say 11 Grand 12 Grand
which is a lovely bit of money if like
there's three of you doing it and you're
not working and that's your only income
that's a good bit of dough well I mean
obviously I wouldn't go into detail I've
had quite a few high value because you
know us had a smaller period when I was
younger where we robbed a few Jewelers
and different bits of Bob scene in terms
of monetary value it would be you know
one particular one was probably close to
half a million pounds